All right, let's
Good?
It's
Okay, folks.
Couple of quick reminders.
There only 5 weeks left in this class.
The spring break is unusually late for
NYU. Usually it's 6 weeks left after the
spring break, but this year, for
whatever reason, they it was moved by a
week.
And that means a whole lot of crap is
going to come at you really fast, right?
First, by this Friday, if you want the
DCF feedback, please get it into me by
5:00 p.m. this Friday.
I mean, I've had my 25 already turned
in, so you know, so as you get a chance,
get it in. I'll get it back to you as
soon as I can. It's not going to be deep
feedback. Deep feedback in the sense,
I'm not going to take issue with your
revenue growth rate, but I might take
issue with the combination of growth and
margins. And make sure you fill that
story worksheet on that spreadsheet, so
you can explain to me what your story is
for your revenue. Cuz without it, it's
just a bunch of numbers. I really can't
give you feedback, right?
That's this Friday. Next Monday is your
second quiz.
It'll cover
pretty much what we did before the
break. There's really nothing we're
going to do today that's going to be a
So, you already have the material for
the quiz.
I put up the review session, the past
quizzes. I will have extra office hours
this Sunday ahead of the quiz.
2 weeks later is your third quiz.
Which is 2 weeks from next Monday.
And And then 2 weeks after that is the
last day of class. Your project is due.
Which is part of the reason I wrote you
that piece about final exams and what's
coming.
Because I did get the time wrong. It's
4:00 to 5:50 p.m. on Monday, the 12th of
May.
Which for some of you is a week you want
to get back home. You want to get back
before the weekend. So, some of you've
asked me whether you can do it early.
You know, I think the best solution
might be, and this is something that I'm
open to being sugges- you know, to to
what you feel is for it to be an online
exam which you take on Brightspace. The
upside of that is you can take it from
anywhere. The downside is it'll be
multiple choice. There's no partial
credit, right? So, I will open it up,
and if you you know, it might end up
that I give both options. So, for people
people who are traveling, they can take
it online at the same time, 4:00 to 5:50
on Monday.
Now, wherever you are in the world, or
if you're in person, you of course show
up in class, you take the exam in
person. But I'm going to give you that
choice. That way you can't complain I
did not give you the choice. The exams
will be essentially equivalent.
So, one will be a multiple choice
version, one will be the other will be a
more traditional exam version. But I'll
let you kind of wrestle with that choice
somewhere along the way. I'll create a
Google shared spreadsheet, so you let me
know whether you're going to take it
online or in person, right?
So, that's for the class. Any questions
logistically about the exams, the
quizzes, what's coming?
So, today we're going to complete our
discussion of intrinsic valuation. Going
to put it to rest.
I'm going to start on pricing.
What's pricing? You basically put a
number on something based on what other
people are willing to pay for it.
Now, one of the statistics I'm going to
point to is most people out there do
pricing. They don't do valuation. We
live in a world of trading and pricing,
not in a world of intrinsic value. We
can complain about
it.
And many analysts, in fact, price
companies. They use a multiple and
comparables. And if you push them,
they'll explain why they don't like to
do discounted cash flow valuation. They
say you have to make all these
assumptions about cash flows, growth,
and risk.
Is that true?
Absolutely, right?
You struggle with that revenue growth
assumption, right? That margin
assumption, that sales to capital
assumption. Even the cost of capital,
you might have had something to fall
back on, but every one of those was
assumptions. They say, "I don't like to
make those assumptions. That's why I
look at EV to EBITDA on other companies
in the sector."
Is it true that you're not making
assumptions about cash flows, growth,
and risk when you use a multiple? Yeah.
Why not?
First, you're assuming that all the
companies are similar in terms of cash
flows, growth, and risk. And if you use
a multiple that's higher, you're
implicitly assuming something about
growth or risk that explains the
difference, right?
The difference is when intrinsic
valuation, your assumptions are
explicit. Everybody can see them. In
pricing, your assumptions are implicit,
which is
extremely dangerous if you think about
it, but it's also easier to defend
because people don't know what you're
assuming, how can they pick on you?
So, one of the things we're going to
talk about in pricing is how to extract
from a multiple your implicit
assumptions about cash flows, growth,
and risk. You might never show this to a
client.
If you're the one selling the pricing,
but at least be aware when you ask for
50 times earnings, what you're assuming
about the company.
Let's assume you estimate the P/E ratio
for every company in the market. It's a
lot easier than it sounds, right? Just
an Excel column, take the And I'm going
to show you what the histogram of P/E
ratios for all US companies looks like.
Now, when you put up the frequency
distribution, can that distribution ever
be normal?
Claire, what do you think?
Can a P/E distribution ever be normal?
First, what's the essence of a normal
distribution? It's symmetric, right? So,
basically it's symmetric, and what are
the tails? What are they What's the
limits on the
It goes from
minus infinity to plus infinity. The
tail never stops out.
Already you can see why P/E ratios can
never be normally distributed. What's
the lowest value P/E ratio can take?
Zero. You can't go below zero. In fact,
if the earnings are negative, it becomes
not meaningful. So, the lowest value
What's the highest value P/E ratio can
take?
You think, "So what? This is a
statistical geek question." One of the
things we're going to talk about is how
that plays out in pricing. When you use
an average P/E, an average EV to EBITDA,
the fact that the distribution is
asymmetric.
And finally, and this goes back to the
earlier point. You know, you look at a
stock and you're looking at its P/E
ratio. Let's say it's 12. And the
average for the sector is 20.
And you write a buy recommendation.
You're an equity research analyst. You
say, "Buy the stock
because it's cheap." It could be, right?
But could it also be expensive? Or could
it be fairly priced?
What are the things we need to control
for?
Suddenly, you know, you're going to see
what the variables are, but let's see if
you can guess them.
One is differences in growth. High
growth companies should have higher P/E
ratios. What else?
Risk. Higher risk companies should have
lower P/E ratios. Let's complete the
cycle. Growth, risk, and
quality of growth, right? So, in this
case, which is cash flow, which is
quality of growth.
If all your companies have equivalent
growth, risk, and quality of growth, of
course a lower P/E ratio company is
cheap. But if they are not, then you
have to control for differences.
And you know how an equity research
analyst controls for differences? Very
badly.
They tell stories.
And we're going to talk about
statistical tools we can use to control
for those differences. So, lots on our
agenda. Let's go back to where I left
you
in the value in our first packet.
We talked about
value I left you with valuing companies
with intangibles.
And one of the quite last valuation I
did was a Birkenstock valuation, where I
did draw some lines, right? I said great
management goes into the growth rate.
Brand name goes into the margin.
The fact that celebrities advertise for
you for nothing goes into that sales to
capital ratio being much higher.
And there's an artificiality in there.
How do you know where each one goes? I
have to make my best judgment. The way I
decided where to put the management was
by looking at the growth rate that
Birkenstock had before this new CEO came
in. It was about 8 to 9. It jumped after
he came in. The margins were already
high. So, I couldn't attribute to the
management. So, in this case, my
judgment call was the growth is where
this is showing up, this great
management.
The margins are high basically because
of brand name.
And the celebrity advertising shows up
in the fact that basically they get a
boost in sales from a Barbie movie being
made. And they didn't pay
any royalties on that movie for Barbie
or maybe they they gave her the pink
Birkenstock for free.
But that's a small price to pay.
But today I want to start by talking
about commodity companies. Any of you
doing oil company Clear, you're doing an
oil company, right?
You're not doing an oil company per se,
an oil distributor or upstream,
downstream?
So, we take any company in the oil space
and you think about the story that
drives the valuation.
A big player in the story has nothing to
do with the company, right? It's the oil
price itself.
I mean, let's take Royal Dutch or
ExxonMobil, mature oil companies.
Let's assume that I went to them right
now. Oil prices right now about $70, $75
a barrel.
And I said, "What are your cash flows?
How much value do you get from growth?
How risky are you? When will you become
a mature company?" I'm going to get a
set of answers. At $74 a barrel,
earnings look pretty good. Cash flows
are pretty solid.
Most of your reserves are viable.
Your risk is low because your cash flows
are high.
And you can tell me a story about
long-term climate change, maybe negative
growth, but it's going to be a pretty
upbeat story.
Let's say 2 months from now I come back
to your company, same company.
Everything about your company stays the
same, but oil prices have gone to $35 a
barrel.
And I ask you, "What are your cash flows
from existing assets?" What's the answer
going to be at 35?
Probably negative. You're going to be
money losing. How many oil companies can
actually make money at 35? What's the
value of growth? Most of your reserves
have turned non-viable, right? You try
to grow, you're going to destroy value.
You're probably going to become risky.
Not because you borrowed money, but
because your existing debt stayed the
same, but your cash flows have dropped
off.
And when will your company be a mature
company? If you're a company with enough
debt, you could be on the verge of
distress. Same company, 2 months later.
If oil prices go to 120, the answers
change again.
The answers you're going to get to your
core questions all come from a macro
variable, not from anything to do with
the company.
So, at the risk of stating the obvious
with these companies, commodity and
cyclical companies, the big player in
the room is the commodity price, what
the economy is doing. And you're going
to be tempted. Tempted in what sense?
You're going to be tempted to forecast
start oil prices. You can see why,
right?
Because if the oil price goes up, your
earnings go up. Why shouldn't I focus on
forecasting oil prices? Because if I can
get the oil price forecast right, I'm
going to get my valuation right. Don't
go there.
And here's why.
Let's assume that Claire believes that
oil price will go from $75 a barrel
right now to 150 in the next 5 years.
She's done her research on demand and
supply for oil.
75 to 150. You put those forecasts into
the valuation of any oil company.
What are you going to find?
Company looks cheap, right?
And then I'm going to ask you, "Are you
finding ExxonMobil or Royal Dutch to be
cheap because you like the company or
because you think oil prices will
double?"
The answer matters because if you say
it's because oil price will double, my
response is, "Why are you buying
ExxonMobil? There's a far easier way for
you to make money. Buy oil futures and
oil options.
If you're really good at forecasting
commodity prices, stop valuing oil
companies.
Just
play the game of forecasting.
And that's why when you value a company,
I want it to be as close to oil price
neutral as you can get. It's much more
difficult than it sounds, as you'll see
when I try to value Royal Dutch. But you
want to take your views about oil prices
out of the picture. I'm not saying you
shouldn't have views. I'll ask you your
views separately because that'll
determine how much of my money should go
into oil companies collectively. But
when I'm trying to decide which
companies to buy, I want to get as oil
price neutral evaluation of each company
as I can get.
So, with oil companies, there is a macro
variable.
And that macro variable is going to
trouble you. Trouble you why? Because it
can keep moving on you.
You think you got your company nailed
down, but 2 weeks later the oil price
moves again.
And here's where
probabilistic tools can come into play.
Have any of you used Crystal Ball, which
is a
NYU Stern has this add-on to Excel. Have
you used Crystal Ball? It's a great
program. It's an Oracle product.
And download and play with it for free
because it's free only when you're a
student. When you leave, you got to buy
your own product. It'll cost you a few
hundred dollars, well worth it though.
Cuz what Crystal Ball will do is take
any Excel spreadsheet
and make it into a Monte Carlo
simulation.
You know what a Monte Carlo simulation
is? Anybody want to explain to me what a
Monte What is a Monte Carlo
Yep. You're taking a historical data,
you assume a distribution, and then you
do that distribution. Okay. First, you
don't have to use You might use
historical values to get the
distribution, but essentially, the way
we do valuation is with point estimates.
You know what I mean by point estimates?
We need to do the FCFF simple Ginzu
spreadsheet. I ask you, "What's the
revenue growth rate?" And I ask for a
number.
"What's your margin?" I ask for a
number. And as you enter these numbers,
part of you is screaming, "But I could
be wrong."
And you're definitely going to be wrong.
What if I let you unleash that scream
and tell me how wrong you could be?
You see what I mean by how wrong? So,
when I ask you, "What's your revenue
growth rate?" instead of entering 23%,
which is your base estimate, you enter a
distribution.
Where 23% is your expected value, but
you say, "Hey, this is what the range
can be, anywhere from 15% to 31%
uniformly distributed." What does that
mean? Be any number from 15 to 31.
Or you can say, "It's going to be 15 to
31 normally distributed." So, you can
put in a standard deviation.
Essentially, instead of entering inputs
that are single numbers, you enter
distributions. You're saying, "What the
heck am I going to do with
distributions?" In a Monte Carlo
simulation, the computer goes and picks
one output or one number out of each
distribution. So, it goes to growth
distribution, picks a number. That
number can be 27%. Margin, picks a
number.
Cost of capital, picks a number, values
a company. Does it over and over and
over again.
Crystal Ball's default is 10,000
simulations.
It can make You can make it 100,000. I
sometimes make it a million just to see
how long it takes a computer. Takes an
extra 2 minutes.
And it'll give you an output of
distribution of values. You're saying,
"What the heck am I going to do this
distribution of value?" I'm going to
take Royal Dutch and take you through
this process so you can see how useful
it can be
to introduce a Monte Carlo simulation on
top of an existing valuation. That's a
nice thing. You can take an existing
Excel spreadsheet that you've already
done the FCFF simple Ginzu and make it
into a Monte Carlo simulation with 2
extra minutes.
We'll talk about the one caveat, which
is you need to remember some statistics
when you do this, especially on
distributions.
So, the company I'm going to value is
Royal Dutch, old-time oil company.
As a valuation I did in 2016 when the
oil prices had dropped briefly to $40 a
barrel.
And I found myself in a quandary. Cuz
the trailing 12-month numbers reflected
an average oil price of $65 a barrel.
Do you see why this is going to be an
issue? If I take the trailing 12-month
numbers, which reflected $65 oil price,
make that my base year, and value the
company, I'm going to overvalue the
company because the oil price had
dropped to $40.
So, I needed to restate the revenues
given that the oil price had dropped to
40.
So, here's what I did first before I did
this valuation. I took the revenues at
Royal Dutch from 1989 through 2015. So,
that's the revenue each year.
Superimposed on it is the average oil
price each year.
Do the two look like they move together?
You're saying my eyes are deceiving me.
Let's do the statistics. R squared is
96.44%.
This is about as pure an oil price play
as you can get.
With an ExxonMobil or Royal Dutch, you
shouldn't be surprised. These are mature
oil companies. It's the oil price that
drives it.
But here's what I did. Once I had the
distribution, I take the revenues for
Royal Dutch and ran a regression against
the average oil price. You're saying,
"What's that going to tell me?" Every $1
increase in the oil price increases my
revenue by about $4 billion.
And here's where having this regression
equation is going to help me. What's
your oil price drop back to? $40 a
barrel, right? I went back and plugged
in the $40 into that regression and got
a predicted revenue for the last 12
months of 201 billion. I'm replacing the
actual trailing 12-month revenue with
this predicted revenue. Why? Because
your oil price has dropped. I want to
restate the revenue to reflect the lower
oil price.
Everything else about the valuation is
pretty standard. I estimate margins and
cash flows. But the lower revenues play
a role in affecting the value. The value
that I got for for company was about $39
per share.
Stock was around 42.
So, I finished this valuation with the
for the Royal Dutch financial group in
Houston.
And some guy in the audience says,
"Well, what if oil prices go to $65 a
barrel?" And I said, "The answer is
going to be easy. The value is going to
be much higher because of $15 a barrel
be much lower."
But obviously, what he was saying is the
big unknown here is not the management,
not the reserves, it's what the oil
price will be in the future.
So, here's where the simulation helped.
One of the nice thing about oil prices,
I do have historical data on oil prices
because oil is traded. You can take
Brent crude and go back 20 years and
look at prices every week, every day if
you want.
I took that historical data
and started with the distribution of oil
prices.
Centered around $40. So, I'm not make
taking an oil price here.
But oil price could be much higher or
much lower.
I drew a number in Crystal Ball out of
the distribution, estimated the revenues
based on that oil price. And that's the
advantage of having run that regression
first.
Came up with margins, cash flows, valued
the company. Did it over and over.
Here's the output from the distribution.
Across I think 10,000 simulations, my
median value was about 37, which is
pretty close to what I got in my base
case.
But here's the additional information I
can get from a Monte Carlo simulation.
Remember how we do best case, worst case
scenarios? It's in there, right? 0 and
100%. In fact, I'd suggest the 10th and
the 90th percentile rather than the
worst and the best.
Think of that as a range on the value.
But there's also additional information.
As you know, last week I sold my Tesla I
sold it a few weeks ago, but I wrote
about it last week on on my and I said,
"Look, I'm looking at BYD, but right now
it looks expensive."
BYD is trading at about $100 per share.
The ADR is
right?
I valued around No, I did evaluation. I
came up with the value of about $80 per
share.
And I did a Monte Carlo simulation on
BYD.
I got a distribution like this. The 30th
percentile in my valuation was about $70
per share.
You say, "What am I going to do with
that?" I put in a limit buy
last week
for BYD at $70 per share.
You say, "What chance you have of
getting it? It's trading at 100." Hey,
prices move. It's a good till canceled.
I'm going to let it sit there. And if I
get lucky, the order will get filled at
70 and it's going to be in my portfolio.
If it doesn't happen, then I'll keep
re-evaluating. One of these days, it's
going to make it.
You know why I want to put the limit buy
in? Because if I wait till the stock
drops to 70, what am I going to be
surrounded by? Lots of bad news, right?
That's why the stock dropped. This way,
I take that decision out of my hands.
I should have put a limit sell on Tesla
at 400.
That would have been sold right after
the election.
I missed that, so I ended up having to
sell it at 320 or 325. Ended up taking
that loss cuz one of the reasons you
want to put those limit orders in is
psychologically,
you're not going to be able to pull the
trigger on selling a really big winner
when the stock price goes up or buying a
company you really want to when the
stock price goes down because everything
around you will be pushing in the other
direction.
So, when you value a company, the value
is lower than the price and you're
disappointed because you really, really
wanted to invest in the company, don't
give up.
Right?
Hold on to the valuation, do a Monte
Carlo simulation, put the limit buy in
at whatever that value is that you're
willing to buy and let it ride. Maybe
it'll happen, maybe it won't. If it
doesn't, it's not the end of the world.
And if it does, you got the stock you
wanted at the value you want to buy it
at rather than the prevailing price.
Yes. What if fundamental information
changes? That's why I can't let it ride
forever, right? So, I will revisit that
limit
Luckily, limit buys, I can cancel and
reset the limit buy price. So, I'm going
to watch BYD's earnings reports. And if
numbers come in really great, maybe I
can move my limit buy up. Who knows what
the price will be. So, it's a moving
target. But you're right, that's
something you have to revisit.
The other thing I find that I can take
out of this is Have you heard of the
margin of safety in value investing?
Seth Klarman, who's a well-known value
investor, wrote a book on the margin of
safety. It's not something It's not
rocket science. Margin of safety
basically means you will buy a stock
only if it's undervalued by 15, 20, 25%.
If you want to really think about
bringing margin of safety into today's
world with data, margin of safety you
can build in here. I will buy only when
a stock hits the 30th percentile or the
35th percentile. It's your margin of
safety.
Any questions?
So, let's Yes, go ahead, Sophia.
It is because you're still basing on an
expected value. There's no premium. The
difference when you talk about options
is there would be a premium we add on
top of DCF valuation. The one by the I'm
glad you made One of the things I look
at is the tail of the distribution.
That's going to tell you something about
the optionality. So, if the distribution
is really long long right tail,
it means there's optionality here. Later
in the in the options section, we'll
talk about how much of a premium you'd
be willing to pay for that optionality.
So, let's wrap up intrinsic valuation,
right?
Intrinsic valuation, what do you do? You
take cash flows, you adjust for risk,
you bring in growth, and you come up
with the present value.
So, the tools are discounted cash flow
valuation, look at the accounting
numbers, it's all about fundamentals.
Pricing is all about demand and supply.
Driven by not just cash flows, growth,
and risk, but by mood and momentum and
all of the behavioral forces. So, it's
something we start with at the start of
the class. So far, we've been almost
entirely on this side of the table.
But the world out there is a pricing
world.
It's demand and supply that are setting
the price for BYD, Tesla, Nvidia, and
the rest of the companies.
And the point I made at the start of the
class is the pricing process and the
value process yield different numbers
and there can be a gap.
Of course, people will take issue with
that, especially if you believe in
efficient markets. If you believed in
efficient markets,
your view is there is no gap, right?
Price and value converge very quickly.
So, what are you going to do? You're
going to buy index funds and you're
going to let the your money ride, which
is perfectly okay.
But I also want to take the two other
extreme views of the world. The first is
what I call the value extremist.
You know where they show up?
You know Omaha, Nebraska every year.
What do they believe that they own the
high ground? That value is the only
thing that matters. Price will move to
them. It's never move them moving to the
price, but the price will move to them.
At the other end of the table, you got
pricing extremists who don't think
there's such a thing as value. That this
is all demand and supply and everything
should be based on demand and supply.
Somewhere between those two extremes,
you might find your middle ground
because I think they're both extremes.
Because I don't buy into the value
extremist that price will move to value,
but I don't buy into the pricing
extremist that there's no such thing as
value as well. But you have to find
your own safe place there.
So, let's talk about as intrinsic value
as a believer in intrinsic value, what
troubles me the most when I take a
position based on intrinsic value. The
first is
I did value BYD. Am I certain about the
value? Of course not. There's so many
things that are out of my control.
Starting with
will the transition to electric cars be
as smooth and as wide as people expect
it to be?
Will BYD end up being one of the
winners? What will the business look
There's so many things I don't know.
I've made my best estimates. I came up
with the value. And I'm going to be
uncertain about that value.
That uncertainty notwithstanding, the
question is how do I deal with
uncertainty? You can put in a margin of
safety, but the truth is that margin of
safety is going to be there no matter
what. You can try to collect more
information. It's not For me, that's
never helped me.
You know, yesterday I was valuing this
Latin American company called Mercado
Libre.
It's a fun company to value, right? You
heard of Mercado?
It's like
I was going to say it's the Amazon
version of in Latin America, but it's
actually very different in one sense.
It's got a very big fintech arm to it
where it provides financing to
customers, lets them deposit their money
in an account where they earn So, it's
like a bank plus an online retailer.
And there's a lot of uncertainty there.
It's Latin America, who knows how the
risk will evolve.
I tried collecting more information, but
the more information I collected, the
more uncertain I felt about the
valuation. And often, I find that to be
the case. You collect more information
thinking it's going to lead you towards
more certainty, it actually diverges.
You can ask what if questions from now
till the cows come home.
Or you can do simulation, but at the end
of the process, the value you get is
still an uncertain number. So, that's
the first thing is how
The second is
even if there's a gap, I don't know
whether that gap will ever close.
And if I believe the gap will close,
when it'll happen.
Right?
So, let's talk about techniques we use,
if you're value investors, to deal with
the gap. The first is what I take what I
call the karmic view. What is the karmic
view?
The I estimated value, the price is what
it is. The gap might close, it might not
close. You essentially say it's out of
my control. Let it ride. It's not an
unhealthy perspective to take cuz all
you control is your estimate of value.
You don't control the pricing process.
You let it play out. The second is
you try to look for a catalyst or you
try to be the catalyst yourself.
I would love to have the power to be the
catalyst. I don't have enough money to
do it.
A Carl Icahn or a Bill Ackman can do it
because they have the money, they have
the the megaphones.
But for most of us we're at the outside
looking in and one of the things I would
suggest you do if you do find a company
to be undervalued is look for something
that can be a catalyst that will cause
the price to move to value.
Any ideas on what what those catalysts
might be? So let's say you find your
company to be undervalued.
Value is higher than the price. What are
some of the things you would look at to
see if there's
a catalyst in there.
Yes.
Okay, so it could be that it's some
event from the outside that because
basically what do you need for a
catalyst? You need the market to be
taking another look at the company,
right? It could be a good good good
Could it be a management change?
I think one of the things I look at and
this is morbid is I look at the age of
the CEO.
I know this is very but 82-year-old CEOs
that's a you know from a catalyst
perspective that's good news because
somewhere very quickly there is going to
be a change.
It could be but it's got to be There's
got to be some news story that you're
expecting happen. So if it's developing
a drug in the FD So there's a there's
clearly a process where the information
is going to Something that will cause
the market reassess. Yeah.
Activist investors but we don't control
them, right? So in a sense you need to
find out if they're on the radar. So
maybe we can get your hands on Carl
Icahn's secret list.
That'd be a good thing to have, right?
Because then you can say, "Hey, they're
going to get on that radar."
Yeah, but you have to figure out when
that happens, right? So you need some
degree of discontent. The board is
looking for somebody else, a new story.
Yeah.
It could be again you have to then
figure out a way in which you can figure
out the likelihood of some company.
Could be. We could In fact, when we talk
about acquisitions we'll talk about
things you can do but essentially we're
looking for something in addition to it
being undervalued that will lead the
market to reassess.
So start thinking about things in your
company which might be the catalyst.
Some news story somewhere, some action
that's going to lead to it. It's
generally not going to be an earnings
report. Unfortunately, it's got to be
something from outside that causes
people to make a reassessment.
So just to give you an example of how
the pricing and the value process go
out. For a long time I've I've tracked
Apple. I've invested in it. This is my
valuation of Apple going back to
September 2011 and start of every year
through 2019. You're saying what
happened in 2019? We'll talk about what
I've done since 2019.
There's my value per share. There's the
price per share.
When I started in September of 2011
my first valuation of Apple I found it
undervalued.
It was already in my portfolio and I
said, "Thank you." All right.
Second valuation it was close to fairly
valued.
I said, "Let it ride." Third valuation
still undervalued but across time you
can see it's gone from being undervalued
to overvalued to undervalued to
overvalued.
Why do you think that is? What's
happening with Apple? What's the market
reacting to?
What's the big event at Apple that leads
to reassessment?
Every time they do an iPhone upgrade
everybody holds their breath, right? If
it goes really well people say, "Oh,
it's amazing. Apple's back to being a
double-digit growth company." They push
up the price.
If that upgrade doesn't go that well
everybody says, "This is the end for
Apple. This And that is what you're
trying to take advantage of." I think
Apple for the last 15 years has been a
mid-single-digit
revenue growth company with an
incredible cash machine on its hands
with iPhone. It's always been the case.
But this is overreaction in the market
in either direction.
Starting September 2019 the stock seems
to have leveled off. It's almost like
the market has finally come to the
conclusion that this will never back go
back to being a great growth company.
Finally, I think Tim Cook has got across
the message of "We're not buying
Netflix. We're not buying Tesla. We're
not going to try to make an electric
car."
And the market is finally believing
them.
Doesn't mean that the volatility is gone
but it's become a much more steady-state
company. In every company there's a
point in its storyline where the story
that you're telling and the story that
the market is telling converge. Doesn't
make it a bad investment. You can then
let it ride because you're not going to
get these wild swings in price and value
over time.
So I'm going to end with a picture.
Anybody know which movie this is from?
Wizard of Oz. How many of you have seen
the original version?
Not my favorite movies but for those of
you haven't let me tell you the story.
It's about
this girl Dorothy. The movie starts with
her on a farm in Kansas. Don't pick on
me about not believing the story. This
is what the story is.
This freak
storm looks like a tornado look I'm not
quite sure what it is sucks her up out
of Kansas.
Carries her through the air
and drops her in this mythical land
called Oz and she lands on top of a
witch. Wicked witch of the East, West I
don't know which which part of the world
she's in and she kills her.
So she's facing homicide charges. That's
how the movie starts. First 5 minutes.
So if you're taking a kid to this movie
skip the first 5 minutes
cuz she's already killed the witch
and she wants to get back to Kansas. So
she turns to this munchkin by the side
of the road and says, "How do I get back
to Kansas?" The munchkin says, "I have
no idea where Kansas is. You got to find
the Wizard of Oz."
She says, "How do I get to the Wizard of
Oz?" Follow the yellow brick road. And
for the next 3 hours that's what she
does. She hops, she skips, she never
walks. If you don't believe me go back
and watch the movie. She hops and she
skips and along the way she collects a
motley crew
of a lion who wants courage, scarecrow,
a tin man. They all want something and
they're all told "Go see the Wizard of
Oz. He has the answer to everything."
It's a long movie. 3 hours later
they get to the Wizard's chambers.
They walk in. The Wizard is behind a
curtain. Don't ask me why. Should
already make you suspicious. So what do
you want? And each of them states what
they want. And he says, "Come back
tomorrow." It's like a government
office.
She says, "I can't come It's been 3
hours. We've been walking all this
distance through the movie just to see
you." That time the curtain drops and
they discover that there is no Wizard of
Oz. It's really a guy behind there
pulling ropes.
But the bottom line is each of them
found what they were looking for on the
journey.
See these red shoes?
Dorothy found them somewhere on the
journey. She clicks them she's back in
Kansas.
The lion fought off some bad guys on the
way, got courage. So each You're saying
what's this got to do with valuation?
Valuation people seem to think that
every question there is a Wizard of Oz
out there. Call it Google search.
What effective tax rate should I use in
valuation? Let's ask the Wizard of Oz.
Here's my advice. Every question you
ever face in intrinsic valuation the
answer is in the process.
Ask yourself what are you trying to do?
Now whether it's effective tax rate,
marginal tax rates, cash flows,
everything every question the answer is
in there.
And if you can find that you can answer
every question you're going to face in
the context of intrinsic valuation no
matter where you run into it or when.
So go back to basic. Whenever you're in
doubt go back to basic cuz the answer is
always there.
You might not believe me now but try it
out the next time you have a question.
You can email me but before you email me
try to reason your way to to the answer
because it is a process that if you work
at it will get stronger each time you
try it.
So any questions on intrinsic valuation
because that is the end of packet one
and we're going to turn to
second packet.
Okay.
No questions on intrinsic valuation?
Let's talk about pricing. Go ahead,
Sophia.
It It depends It's a very It's a very
good question. Sophia's question is what
if you have two very divergent
businesses which have very different
margins, very different growth rates,
very different stories.
We already ran into it in Nvidia.
Separate the AI chip business from the
rest of business. With Tesla
there was the automotive business, the
the automated driving business, the
robotics business.
If you have businesses which are going
to be moving with different storylines,
with different characteristics, it does
make sense to separate them because
you're telling a different story. The
one thing about financing arms is if
they're completely captive financing
arms. I don't think of them as a
financial business. You know what I mean
by completely captive?
Volkswagen Capital
provides financing to only one group of
people which is
people who buy Volkswagens.
So Volkswagen Capital I think of the
financing arm as an extension of the I
wouldn't separate it out.
With Mercado in addition to financing
stuff on the platform, they also have a
separate business on credit cards.
There I would separate the business out
because it is different enough, needs a
different story.
So, if your financing arm is a captive
financing arm, I would leave it embedded
in the company, just value the company.
If it is separate financing arm with its
own business lines that are separate
from the main business, then I think it
makes sense to tell a different story.
Let's talk about pricing. Hey, let's go
back to the What What are we trying to
do? I'm going to go between these words,
relative valuation and pricing, because
in my at least in my language that
they're saying the same thing. In
pricing, you're trying to attach a
number to an asset based on what other
people are paying for similar assets.
So, think about what you need to do a
pricing. First, you need to find those
comparable companies or pure group,
things that look just like your company,
right? Or if it's another asset, other
assets that look just like yours. That's
the first step.
Second stop,
you might have to standardize the price.
Let's go outside stock. Let's suppose
you have two buildings next to each
other, but one is a 12-story building,
the second is a four-story building.
You know how in real estate we compare
the pricing? We divide the price of each
building by the number of square foot,
price per square foot. Why? Cuz the
price itself cannot be comparable. With
stocks, that comparison becomes even
more difficult. You can't compare the
price per share across companies, you
might have to standardize prices. A
multiple is just a standardized price.
Third step, if you're careful, you
should control for differences between
the company or the asset you're valuing
and all of the other
the pure group.
I'm going to start with a contention.
Much of what you see out there, many of
you when you go to work will find
yourself pricing things rather than
valuing them. And you'll be disappointed
because you want to bring your DCF
skills out and your revenue growth and
your margins and your air managing and
not none of that stuff. Use a PE ratio
on these 20 companies and tell me how
much to pay. The world is a pricing
world and intrinsic valuation feels like
an outsider.
Let me back up that statement.
About 20-plus years ago, I collected 550
equity research reports from around the
world. I'll confess I didn't read most
of them.
I collected them because I wanted to
chronicle how equity research analysts
put buy and sell recommendations on
stocks.
Out of the 550, 45 45 were intrinsic
valuations, less than 10%.
450 were pricing, multiple and
comparables, and the other 55 I couldn't
quite classify. They were kind of scary.
So, let's put that 55 to the side, but
among the ones I could classify, 10 to
one,
pricing outnumbered valuation.
They said, maybe it's different in
corporate finance. So, I found about 100
acquisition valuations. Really tough to
do because bankers hide those behind
lock and key after they've done them cuz
you really don't want to see what
synergy numbers they use and compare
them to the actual numbers.
But I have my sources. I found 100
acquisition valuations, and there at
first sight it looked like 50/50.
Half were DCFs and half were pricing,
but then I took a closer look at the
DCFs and I realized
they were pricing in drag.
And you know exactly what I'm talking
about, right? What's the biggest number
in a DCF? The terminal value, and that
was estimated by using eight times
EBITDA, two times book value, or five
times revenues.
Much of what you see out there is
pricing. And when I first did this, I
was puzzled.
I was puzzled because at the end of this
class, I'm going to do an exit survey
after you finished your project.
So, you've done an intrinsic valuation
and pricing. At the end of the class,
I'm going to say, "Now that you've
attached a number to your company based
on both the discounted cash flow
valuation and pricing, if I asked you to
pick an approach, which one would you
pick?"
And I'm going to let you make the
choice.
And I'm not going to put any pressure on
you, but the
Well, I've done that survey now for for
almost the entire
three decades I've taught this class,
three decades plus. And every time I do
the survey, I get about a 70/20/10
breakdown. 70% of the people leaving
this class, when they leave the class,
say they're believers in intrinsic
valuation, perhaps reflecting my biases.
About 20% say, "Look, pricing is much
easier. I believe in it more." And about
10% become believers in efficient
markets after they've tried to put a
number on a company and decided, "Hey,
that wasn't that easy."
72, when people leave my class, they
walk out as believers in intrinsic
valuation. I'll wager, if I track these
people down 5 10 years later doing it
whatever job they're in, bankers, equity
research analysts, hedge fund managers,
that the numbers flip.
That 70% become pricing people 20
Something seems to happen between the
time you leave this classroom and you
get on a desk that leads people to
abandon intrinsic valuation and become
pricing people.
So, I've wrestled with what could those
be?
And the first one came to me while I was
watching a Seinfeld episode.
As you all know, I spend a lot of my
time watching useless TV.
And Seinfeld, of course, the
quintessential New York sitcom.
In this episode, one of Jerry's
girlfriends accuses him of being crazy.
And he says, "If you think I'm crazy,
you should see the guy who lives across
the hall from me."
You know who lives across the hall from
Jerry?
A guy called Kramer who's so crazy that
relative to him, everybody looks sane.
You see?
So, what's this got to do with pricing?
We forget how much of pricing is
selling.
You want to sell me something as cheap.
You know what you need to show me?
Something that's even more expensive.
Essentially,
much of what we do in in so banking is
selling, equity research is selling, and
it's easier to sell a pricing than it is
to sell a discounted cash flow
valuation.
Second,
it's easier to defend a pricing than to
defend a discounted cash flow valuation.
I could nitpick your DCF to death,
right? Why this growth rate? Why this
margin? Your cost of capital looks off.
Your equity risk premium weights don't
look right.
It's all there for me to pick apart. In
contrast, if I said I'm pricing this
company at $85, which is eight times
EBITDA because that's what other
companies in this group are priced at.
Think of the target I've given you.
You don't like eight times EBITDA? My
response is take it up with the market.
It's not my fault.
40 times revenues, you might think it's
expensive, but that's what everybody
else is paying.
Pricing is easier to sell, it's easier
to defend. And there's a final reason
why I think pricing ends up dominating.
I told you I'm a believer in intrinsic
valuation, but I'm a realist.
If I do intrinsic valuation right,
I might be right 57 times out of 100,
and I'll take that. It's better than
50/50.
I think if you do pricing really well,
you could be right 52 times out of 100.
So, you're saying 57 beats 52? You're
right. But here's the catch. When I'm
wrong with intrinsic valuation, I'm far
more likely to be wrong alone.
You see why?
In intrinsic valuation, you're likely to
be a contrarian. You're buying stock
when everybody else is selling. You're
selling stock when everybody else is
buying.
So, you if you're wrong, you're going to
be wrong alone. You know what happens to
people who are wrong alone?
They get fired.
Survival will often lead you to pricing
cuz that way if you make a mistake, you
have lots of company.
When I first started teaching this
class, I used to try to convince people
to do intrinsic valuation. I no longer
do that because many of you will have
jobs that require you to price things.
I have to be realist.
So, what we're going to spend in the
next few sessions is talk about how to
do pricing better rather than how bad
pricing is, because that's a mistake we
often make in these valuation class. We
talk about multiples as shallow and
But the reality is that is your job.
It's a pricing job.
So, let's set the process rolling by
thinking about what it is about pricing
that leads this drive towards it. The
first is, pricing is more likely to
reflect the market mood.
You're saying, "Is that a good thing? Is
that a bad thing?" It depends on what
your job is, right? If your objective is
to sell an IPO, crowd You know the crowd
What was it? CrowdStrike, that AI IPO
that came out? What's your job as a
banker? To get the highest price you can
for that IPO. Not the highest value, but
the highest price.
Your job is pricing.
If you're a portfolio manager, your job
is pricing. You're judged against other
people who do the same thing. You have a
pricing mission rather than a valuation.
So, I'll wager that most of you when you
get a job, there'll be a valuation in
your title, but if you look at what
you're doing, almost everything you're
doing is pricing.
So, let's set the process start the
process, yeah? You can't compare the
price per share across companies.
Saying, "Why not?" If I just use price
per share as my measure of cheap or
expensive, what's the most expensive
stock in the US?
Berkshire. Which trades at what? 650,000
700,000 dollars per share. And the
cheapest stock would be a penny stock,
right? Trades at only two cents. But you
see the problem with that? It's
completely arbitrary.
I can have the price for any company by
do it doing a two-for-one stock split.
Nvidia's price dropped about 90% a few
months ago.
You know why?
They did a 10-to-one stock split.
Completely arbitrary, right, Pusha?
So, what do we do? We divide the price
by something to standardize it. It's not
rocket science.
Every multiple, if you break it down, in
the numerator, there's usually a market
number. It can be the market value of
equity, which is called market cap.
Share price times number of shares. It
can be the market value of equity plus
the market value of debt. There are lots
of people cheat and just use book debt
because they can't get market debt.
That's market value of the firm. Or you
can take market value of equity plus
debt minus cash,
which is called enterprise value, which
is the market value of the operating
assets of the company. Numerator is a
market number.
And then you scale the market number to
some common metric. That common metric
can be revenues.
Why would you use revenues?
Because you got desperate, right? You're
looking for a positive number. Every
number is negative. You keep So, in in
sectors where everybody's losing money,
you're going to see a lot of revenue
multiples.
What if your company is pre-revenue?
I was thinking it's like you need price
to price by number of subscribers.
In other words, you look for something
that might give you revenues, right?
Which is I have a lot of subscribers.
One of these days they will start paying
me.
Market value per subscriber user. So,
revenues are revenue drivers.
You can divide by earnings. Those
earnings can be to equity investors, net
income or earnings per share, or they
can be to the entire firm, operating
income.
It can be cash flow. In case of equity,
that can be net income plus
depreciation.
Kind of a half-assed measure of cash
flow because you know, where's the
CapEx? Where's the change in working
capital? So, if you wanted to, you can
make it free cash flow to equity. Or it
can be to the firm. Again, the
half-assed version is to take EBIT and
add back the dot, the EBITDA.
Or you can do free cash flow to the
firm. So, you got revenues, you got
earnings, you got cash flow.
Or you can divide by or you can scale it
to book value. That's what the account
tells you what the equity is worth, what
the firm is worth.
Or if he's giving you firm plus, you
know, debt plus equity minus cash, the
invested capital. So, numerator is
always a market number.
The denominator is a scalar.
Next time you see a multiple, you can
open up Bloomberg, you open up Yahoo
Finance, there'll be a bunch of
multiples. Just an exercise. Take them
up and break them down. What's in the
numerator? What's in the denominator?
So, I'm going to give you a four-step
process that if you're religious about
following with multiples, you're going
to be okay doing pricing.
I'm going to bore you by using this
four-step process over and over again
with every multiple we run into because
I will almost want to make it second
nature. So, when I throw a multiple at
you, you take it through the process.
First step in the process is I'm going
to start by defining the multiple.
And I'm going to put it through two
tests. Is it consistently defined?
And is it uniformly estimated? Sounds
like I'm playing on words, but I'll talk
about specifics about what I mean with
each of those. Consistently defined,
uniformly estimated.
Second stop,
I'm going to describe the multiple. I'm
going to play Moneyball.
Seen the movie?
Basically, the movie is about Billy
Beane, Oakland A's GM,
essentially bringing in a What's this
with MIT guys in baseball, huh?
This MIT guy who invented a baseball bat
might become the most famous MIT grad of
all time.
Brings in So, the movie is about, you
know, Billy Beane bringing in an MIT guy
using numbers to gauge who he should
sign. We're going to play Moneyball with
the data. Look at what's high, what's
low, the distribution of the data.
Define, describe.
Third step, I'm going to take every
multiple and look at what drives that
multiple. When I look at P/E ratio, what
are the questions I need to ask? What
are the variables I need to control for?
And only then am I going to apply the
multiple. Define, describe, analyze,
apply.
So, let me go and structure the process
so you can see what's going on.
You come to me with a multiple. There
are two questions I'm going to ask you.
One is, is this multiple consistently
defined?
And here's the way you check it. Your
numerator, if it's an equity value, your
denominator has to be an equity value as
well.
Your numerator, if it's a firm or an
enterprise value, your denominator has
to be a firm or an enterprise value as
well.
I know it's cruel and unusual punishment
to hit you with this late in the day.
But I'm going to throw a few multiples
at you,
and you tell me whether they're
consistently defined.
Let's start with P/E ratio.
Most widely used multiple in the world.
What's in the numerator? Equity value,
enterprise value, firm value.
P/E ratio.
The market value of the equity. Market
cap or price per share. It's equity
value. What's in the denominator?
Earnings per share.
Equity earnings per share. So, thank god
for small blessings, the most widely
used multiple in the world is okay. P/E
ratio is an equity multiple.
What about EV to EBITDA? Help me out
here. What's in the numerator?
Enterprise value. Which is the market
value of the operating assets of the
company. And in the denominator, you
have EBITDA, which is a rough measure of
operating cash flow. So, EV to EBITDA is
okay. What about price to EBITDA?
But I'm sorry. No sense. Price to
EBITDA, the numerator is an equity
value, denominator is an operating cash
flow.
Seven Remember the 550 equity research
reports I looked at. Seven used price to
EBITDA to put a recommendation. One of
them happened to be somebody who went
through this class
a few years before. So, I gave him a
call.
I said, "Uh remember that valuation
class you took a few years ago?"
He said, "Vaguely."
I said, "It shows."
I said, "What the heck are you doing
dividing market cap, which is an equity
value, by EBITDA, which is an operating
cash flow? You're not being consistent."
He said, "No, no, I'm being consistent."
I said,
"In what sense?" He said, "I used price
to EBITDA for all 15 companies in my
sector."
I said, "That's interesting. Have you
been noticing that companies with a lot
of debt keep looking cheap to you?"
He said, "Yes, yes, I've been noticing
that." I said, "Have you ever stopped
and thought about why that might be
happening?"
Do you see why using price to EBITDA is
going to make highly levered companies
look cheap to you? What's in the
numerator? Just the equity value, right?
So, if I borrow money and retire equity,
buy back stock, my equity value shrinks.
My EBITDA is my EBITDA. It's before
interest, taxes, depreciation,
amortization. I can borrow money till
the cows come home, and my EBITDA
doesn't move.
If you use price to EBITDA, you are
consistently going to find levered
companies look cheap. Before you feel
too superior to this guy, if you've ever
used price to sales,
you're guilty of the same sin, right?
Analysts use it all the time. You know,
how do they get away with it? Why do
they get away with A lot of analysts use
price to sales.
How do they get away with it if it's not
consistent?
What about the assets?
That can't help you, right? If it's
highly levered, you're over buying that.
That's a very pragmatic reason for using
it. You want a lot of buy, but you know,
it still doesn't protect you if you
bought over what it's
I think one has to assume that the
margin that you multiply the sales
by to get to
Okay, then you control What sectors is
price Do you Do you know what sectors
price to sales show up most in?
Technology.
And what What What's true about
technology in terms of debt?
They tend to borrow very It's
accidental. You got away with it because
there wasn't much debt to begin with. If
you tried price to EBITDA with cable
companies, it would jump out at you
saying,
"This company looks like it's trading at
half of EBITDA." And then you look at
the amount of debt it has and realize
you've screwed up.
The reason they've gotten away with it
is complete luck.
The sectors they're in have so little
debt that using price didn't get them
into trouble.
But if you were doing this from scratch,
you say, "Why are you using price to
EBITDA? Why not use EV I'm sorry, price
to sales? Why not use EV to sales? It's
a much more consistent version."
So, is it consistently defined? Check
the numerator, check the denominator,
make sure that they're matched up.
Second question, is it uniformly
estimated? Remember what we do with
this, right? We estimate P/E ratio for
15 companies, and we compare across the
15 companies.
You have to make sure that you're
estimating earnings exactly the same way
for all 15 companies. You're saying,
"But the accounting standards are the
same. They're all covered by GAAP."
I used to think that
until the late '90s when we discovered
that they could all be you covered by
the same accounting standards and have
different degrees of fidelity to those
standards.
You could be an aggressive company, not
break the rules, or a conservative
company. An aggressive company is always
going to look cheap on you because
they're just
playing the discretion they have to
report higher earnings.
When you do pricing, you got to be a lot
more careful about comparing across
companies. So, in that sense, it's a lot
more work, right? You're comparing 15
companies.
Is it consistently estimated? Is Is it
consistently defined, uniformly
estimated? So, let's try
consistency test on a few multiples. We
already said that price earnings is
consistently defined.
Everybody seems to know what a P/E ratio
is, right?
Even Anna Kournikova knew what a P/E
Remember Anna Kournikova? She
masqueraded as a tennis player for like
a decade.
She's a Russian tennis player. She's
like the Maria Sharapova without the
talent.
Was in every commercial you could think
of.
And there was this Charles Schwab
commercial that she showed up in like
2001.
The commercial
Anna Kournikova is playing somebody.
Must have been an actress because she
was actually winning.
So in tennis every two games you switch
sides so that because you don't have the
sun in your eyes. So they're switching
sides and for whatever reason in the
middle of a tennis match
Anna turns to whichever the actress
she's playing and she says price
earnings ratio is price divided by
earnings per share and she kept going
with something to do with preferred
dividends that went completely over my
head.
But I turned off the TV and started
thinking, does Anna Kournikova really
know what the P/E ratio is?
The numerator is usually the current
price, right? Unless you're one of those
technical analysts gone crazy. You ever
talk to them? They love moving averages
for everything.
To which my response is, have you ever
tried buying a stock at a moving average
price?
I wanted to put a moving average price
on BYD and say, can you buy me? It
doesn't work. It's current price.
But in the denominator is where you get
the variance, right? I can divide price
per share by earnings per share in the
most recent fiscal year.
Which for some of your companies is
still 2023.
I can divide price per share by earnings
per share in the last four quarters.
It's called trailing P/E.
I can divide price per share in the
expected earnings per share in the next
four quarters, which is forward P/E.
Or I can divide price per share by
expected earnings per share in the year
2029, which is really, really forward
P/E.
Saying, why would I do that? Again, in
desperation.
You're analyzing biotech companies,
they're all losing money. The only tool
you have is P/E. So what do you do? You
project the earnings out till they turn
positive. Say, this stock looks cheap.
It's trading at eight times 2029
earnings. I don't even know what to do
with that.
What do you have? A ratio.
I can divide by earnings per share
before extraordinary items, after
extraordinary item, before stock-based
compensation, after stock-based
compensation, before lease conversions,
after lease conversions.
You take any high-profile company, like
Cisco.
And you compute the P/E ratio today
using different definitions of earnings
per share, you can get numbers ranging
from 18 to 45 for the company.
Saying, which one should I use? Depends
on what your agenda is.
If you're trying to convince me to buy
Cisco, which of those ratios do you
latch onto?
Cisco is cheap. It's trading at 18. You
never mention the 45. You're trying to
convince me it's expensive, you go to
the other end of the spectrum.
Price earnings ratios are consistent,
but that doesn't mean when you talk
about P/E and I talk about P/E that
we're talking about the same thing.
My advice is if you're ever in a
negotiation about a multiple, before you
get into the numbers, start by nailing
the definition down to to make sure
you're talking about the same thing.
Now, a related issue, and this is
especially true in technology companies.
You remember we're talking about per
share earnings, right? How do we get per
share earnings? We take the net income
and divide by the number of shares.
With technology companies you can have
shares, primary shares, which is only
the shares outstanding. You can also
have diluted shares, which include
shares that you might have to issue to
cover options. You can have partially
diluted shares, where you count only the
options in the money. You can get very
different estimates of earnings per
share.
So I have a very generic question. Let's
say you're looking at a software
business. There are 45 companies
in your sector. You've taken the price
per share, which is obviously what's out
there.
You computed the earnings per share and
you're trying to come up with a measure
of earnings per share that is not going
to create a biased outcome. You're
picking companies that look cheap, but
they're really not cheap.
Which variant of earnings per share
should you use
to come up with a number that you can
actually compare across companies? If I
use primary earnings per share, the
actual earnings count.
What kinds of companies would So assume
that these companies have different
numbers of options outstanding in the
money, out of the money.
Which kinds of companies would look
cheap to you if you use price divided by
primary earnings per share?
What happens if you have a lot of
options outstanding?
In other words, the market knows you
have a lot of options outstanding, the
price per share goes down. You divide by
earnings per share, the P/E ratio is not
going to capture the fact that you have
all these So
when you have a lot of options
outstanding, the price per share will
reflect it. But if you haven't captured
that in the earnings per share, these
companies are going to look cheap.
If you go to the other extreme and you
divide by diluted earnings per share, if
you have a lot of options outstanding
and they turn out to be out of the money
options,
I'm penalizing you for something I
shouldn't be penalizing you.
I'm going to give you some bad news. If
you have a lot of options outstanding,
don't do per share numbers.
Per share numbers are going to be
problematic. There is no solution.
Primary, diluted, partially diluted,
that's going to work. Saying, how the
heck am I going to compute P/E ratio?
If you don't have per share numbers,
what can you do?
You can take the market cap of the
company.
Include the option value, right?
Remember when we did DCF as well. Take
that. That's the total value of equity.
Divide by total net income. This way you
completely avoid the issue of per share
numbers. It's the cleanest way of
dealing with different numbers of
options outstanding across companies.
Market cap plus value of options in the
numerator, total net income in the
denominator.
Talk about enterprise value to EBITDA.
When I first started in in investing in
markets,
you barely ever You know, you hardly
ever ran into EV to EBITDA in in in any
kind of equity research board. Maybe one
in 50.
Mid '80s.
Today, 1/3 of all sell-side equity
research uses EV to EBITDA multiples.
So many of you will end up working in
banks
or portfolio management firms where EV
to EBITDA becomes the prime metric.
In the numerator, of course, you have
market value of equity plus debt minus
cash.
In theory, that debt should be market
value, but many investment banks will
use book value because market value can
be tough to look up because these bank
debt might not be traded. So I can live
with that. Minus cash. In the
denominator, you have earnings before
interest, taxes, depreciation, and
amortization.
When I run into analysts who use EV to
EBITDA, I ask them a very simple
question. I almost never get the right
answer. Let's see if you can give me the
right answer.
Why do we net cash out of the numerator
when we do EV to EBITDA? Yeah. It only
belongs to equity holders.
So why net it out? Why not leave it
there then? So what do you mean it only
belongs In a sense, everything only
belongs to equity investors, right?
Enterprise value capturing the value
that is distributed to equity and debt
holders. Yeah. But the cash is only
available to But if you're capturing
what's to equity and debt holders and
the cash belongs to them, why not leave
it in there?
I'm not getting that final link that
will lead you to net it out, right? So
equity investors own the cash and you're
trying to get the total value of equity.
Yes.
The non-operating
You're getting closer. Look at the
denominator. The answer is going to be
right there. What's in the denominator?
EBITDA, right?
Does cash have income? Does interest
income, but where does the interest
income usually show
It shows up below the EBITDA line item.
The reason we net cash out is the income
from cash is not part of my EBITDA.
And actually you've opened the door. In
addition to cash, what else do I need to
net out of the numerator?
What other What are the non-operating
assets we talk about whose income is not
part of my EBITDA or EBIT?
It's part of the second quiz, big part.
It's cross holdings. Remember small
percentages of other companies, 5%, 7%,
10% of another company?
That is a cross holding, it's a
non-operating asset, the income is not
part of EBITDA. I need to net those out
as well.
It's a huge factor when you have cross
holding companies. Cleaning up your
enterprise value for those cross
holdings becomes critical.
What if I have a majority holding?
Okay, play it out. If I have a majority
holding, what does my market value of
equity include? Let's say I own 60% of
company B. Okay. What is my What is the
market I only 60%? Yeah, so the market
value of equity includes only 60%. But
everything else comes from consolidated
financials, right? My debt will have
100%. My EBITDA is 100%. So I have an
outlier. Everything other than market
value of equity is at 100%, but the
market value of equity is at 60%.
So how do I fix this? What can I What
What are you going to add to the
numerator?
The
non-controlling The minority interest.
And that's what analysts do, is they add
the 40% back. It's a You know, you have
to admit it's a half-assed way of doing
it. Why? Because everything else is in
market value terms, but that 40% is a
book value number.
It's a nightmare to estimate EV to
EBITDA for companies with cross
holdings.
So play that game out. Play minority
holdings, majority holdings, and you're
very quickly going to see that the EV to
EBITDA takes a little work to get there.
One final example of for consistency.
For the longest time, real estate and
equity have been kind of separated as
markets. So real estate people talk
about housing prices and equity people
talk about equity prices and it's almost
like the never the twain shall meet.
But in housing, there is actually a
multiple, a pricing multiple that gets
used to judge whether housing is
expensive or not. And that is to take
the value of the housing price and
divide it by the net rental income on a
house.
You take the housing price, divide by
net rental income. Net of what? Net of
the expenses with renting that property
out.
Let's say I come up with that for real
estate as a whole.
The housing price divided by net rental
income. And I'm trying to decide whether
to put my money into housing or into
equities.
What is the equivalent multiple I would
use in equity to match up against
housing price to net rental income? What
is it closest to? Is it closest to PE
ratio, and EV to sales, and EV to
EBITDA, and EV to EBIT?
Yeah.
I would say hence it could be C or D.
Um people do it differently whether or
not they add the reserve.
But why isn't it Why isn't it A? So why
why why do you rule out A right off the
top?
In the wire net rental income, you don't
include the And I include I did the
whole price of the house. I didn't do
the equity portion of the price. I did
the whole price of the house. So it's
closer to enterprise value. So it's
clearly an enterprise value in the
numerator. And you're right, it can
either be EBITDA or EBIT depending on
how I define the net rental income. If
I'm not adding the depreciation back,
I'm just looking at the net rental
income, it is closer to EBIT. If I'm
adding the depreciation back to it, it
gets closer to EBITDA.
It's actually fascinating graph out EV
to EBIT for the market and housing
prices to rental income over time
because it actually does a very good job
of telling you when housing is in a
bubble. It's just nobody seems to notice
because it's almost like the markets are
bifurcated and they're not comparing
these numbers.
So is it consistently defined? Is it
uniformly estimated?
Second stop.
Remember your statistics. When I would
give you a lot When you're given a lot
of data, what are the first things you
check? What's the average? What's the
standard deviation?
As a follow-up though in your statistics
as I know how much is emphasized, do a
histogram.
Sounds fancy, but what do you do? You
just count, right? Count the number of
stocks PE ratios 0 to 4, 4 to 8, 8 to
12. Put up the histogram. It's going to
tell you something about the data.
Rather than talk in the abstract, let me
show you the histogram for PE ratios for
US stocks at the start of 2025.
Actually at the start of every year, I
take every publicly traded stock in the
world and I compute eight different
ratios: PE, price to book, price to
sales. And then I put up these
histograms.
This is a histogram for just US stocks
of three versions of the PE ratio:
trailing PE,
current PE, forward PE. Current PE is
when I divide by the last fiscal year.
Since I do it on January 1st 20 of each
year, this will be usually 1 year
before, right? So 2025 January 1st, the
most recent fiscal year was 2023.
Trailing PE, current PE, forward PE.
We talked about distributions not being
symmetric.
Peak is to the left, tail is to the
right. And I've artificially cut off the
tail to the right by putting all stocks
with the PE ratio greater than 100 into
one pile. If I let that run out, the
tail will basically take over this
entire chart and I'll have a little
You think so what?
I don't know whether your statistics
professor ever said this, but mine said
if you have an asymmetric or a skewed
distribution like this one, he said
never trust the average.
Why not?
What is it about this distribution that
should make the average not trustworthy?
Yeah. A small portion is very high and a
large portion is very low. So when you
get an average, it's skewed. It was In
other words, the outliers are all in one
side of the distribution, right? You
have big positive numbers, but you don't
have big negative numbers. The big
positive numbers are always going to
exercise the law of gravity, pull the
average up. Say how much can it matter?
Start of 2025, the average PE for US
stocks was 57.11. That's scary high,
right? That's the average.
The median
was 18.66. You can tell how skewed a
distribution is by looking at that
difference. This is a extraordinarily
skewed distribution. And why is it so
skewed? Because the lowest PE ratio was
zero, but the highest PE ratio was
7,900.
And that's actually low by historical
standards. Last year, the highest PE was
103,550.
Say that must be one highly priced
stock. The earnings per share dropped to
a fraction of a cent
and the PE ratio had gone through the
roof.
You know the first lesson from this is,
if you're doing pricing, never ever talk
about averages. Averages are
meaningless. Talk about medians. Talk
about quartiles. Talk about
distributional numbers cuz the averages
tell you nothing.
Also, if you notice there are 6,062 US
companies in my sample this year.
When I did current PE, I had only 2,600.
What happened to the other 3,600?
Where did they go?
They had negative earnings. You're
saying, "What's the big deal? You still
have 2,600. It's a big enough sample."
Am I creating some bias in my sample by
throwing out all my negative earnings
companies? Absolutely, right? They tend
to be small, risky.
It's a challenge I wrestle with at the
start of every year because I compute
industry average numbers or industry
typical numbers.
And the reason I wrestle with industry
average numbers is if I just take the PE
ratios of every company in the industry
and take the average,
I'm missing all those companies negative
earnings. And in sectors like biotech
where a big chunk of the sector is
negative earnings, I'm getting a very
skewed number.
See now how I try to resolve it? I take
the market values of every company in
every in the industry, divide by the
total net income including the
money-losing companies of every company.
I report what's called an aggregated PE.
I also have a median. I think it's much
better when you look at large samples to
do either an aggregated or median number
rather than look at the average.
In fact, as I go from current PE to
trailing PE to forward PE,
especially with forward PE, I lose
another 200 companies.
Why is that?
You need forward earnings. I'm not
sitting there projecting earnings for
6,000 companies. You know what I'm
looking at, right? Analysts'
projections. If a company is not tracked
by analysts,
I kick it out of my sample.
Does that create bias? Absolutely
because the kinds of companies that are
not tracked by analysts are very
different from the companies that are.
We introduce bias in the most subtle
ways when we do pricing.
One of the reasons I make you pick your
peer group is your biases will come into
play. At least be aware of what those
biases are and where they will lead you
in because every criterion you're adding
to that peer group is introducing a bias
into that peer group.
Might as well be aware of that bias.
So define, describe. Next session we
start off, we're going to start with
analyze. But we have a few more things
we can do with the describe part that
I'll complete first. So I will see you
on Wednesday.
Hi Professor.
So the the capital IQ that we use for
the DCF
Um
I sent an email for Stern and my email
address, but I did not get the email
response. Is that the way we're supposed
to do it to get the
The university uh
Hi. Um so the thing with Swan is like a
little weird because the taxes
are dependent on like the state law.
How would you go about calculating the
taxes there?
Uh it's it's different in states. States
like
No, it's different in states. I think it
Yeah, it's different.
Okay.
It's a club line.
Right, but there's also income tax.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but I do include that.
They don't sell the tax
Yeah.
And then I can still use that to
calculate like free cash flow. Like
let's assume normal.
And then I can project it.
Okay.
I know SPACs are like less popular now.
They can't be like reversed ever, right?
No, no, no. Like they they they are
successful.
Yeah.
Right.
Would that count as M&A activity?
No, it's not.
Okay.
So, how would it be reported on the
earnings?
The company that got acquired?
Yeah.
Now you've gone from a private company
to
How would I show that?
Is Is there a minority interest? No.
Right.
So, there's no way to find the value of
the
Right.
But not of like debt
or
Oh, so I just like would just increase.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Right. And then when you're doing the
Monte Carlo simulation, how did you come
up with like the possible values? Cuz
you're saying Yeah, you're saying
Okay.
Right. But like the 30%, 40% like you
just made up
Okay.
You're not using oil prices.
But that's where you get the 30, 40,
50%.
Okay.
Okay, got it. Thank you.
Sorry for the interruption.
I just want to know, is the second um
quiz going to be like whatever we ended
off for the first quiz? Forward or is it
just everything included?
Okay.
Okay. Thank you.
I have a quick question. So, I'm valuing
Stellantis, which is a car company.
Yeah. Yeah. So,
the and then Trump did all that 25%
stuff. What do you think that that's
going to affect my revenue
and my margin?
Um for the first I think for a year or
two it does, but then it goes
Yeah. Not really because uh Stellantis
has like a lot of US-based um factories.
So, I would think they would get an
edge.
Yeah.
So, they would get an edge compared to
the other
They get a lot of their stuff for the US
factories
Yeah.
Right.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Might be negative.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
You lose from every side.
No, yeah. But what
where would I see that effect mostly in
my story line?
Yeah.
And
And the way this calculated is also like
looking at price elasticity
and seeing like
like projecting what how much it would
increase or stuff like that?
That is specific. Okay.
Marginal, okay.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
You see this being long-term though?
Like
these 25%
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe not the right company to value
this to this week. Thank you.
Professor, what do you think about like
the gold the current gold market? Do you
think that gold will have an important
role in the next few years? Has gold
always had an important role?
Well, this It's been part of it. I know.
year it's up so much. People think gold
is more important than before.
Why?
What is it that makes gold more more
attractive or less attractive? What is
gold's history? I mean, gold's been
around 4,000 years. What's its primary
role been?
Store of value. So, the way I see it now
Store of value and
as a currency.
Relative to what? Relative to Paper
currencies, right?
So, the less trust you have in paper
currencies, the more gold will go up.
So, that's why it goes up during
inflation. That's why it goes up during
crisis. So, when you lose trust in
governments and paper currencies,
gold is So, there's a reason why gold
has gone up this year. People are
feeling
unsteady and shaken by what's happened.
They're going to go to gold.
So, but I think gold has to I mean,
you're tracking us. Gold can only be
priced. It can't be valued. Priced
relative to
financial assets. And right now that
pricing goes up because people don't
trust financial assets as much.
Right, right. I see.
Yeah, thank you. You're welcome.